[Music]
5 55 on your wednesday morning hey we're
learning more about some little noticed
mysterious signs near
southern nevada freeways a viewer by the
name of alex i don't think it's our alex
it's a question that you might have
wondered about too
like what's the deal with signs like
these around the city have you seen them
alex wrote that it looks like they can
alternate be alternate between
interstate or u.s highways with room for
info at the top and bottom
alex writes i've seen them on various
streets near highway entrances for years
but they've never been turned on
we'll have another tip of the driving
crazy hat to nevada department of
transportation spokesman tony ilya for
this answer he says
those are called trailblazer signs that
136 were installed around the valley in
the early 2000s
he writes their solar powered radio
controlled electronic signs are supposed
to activate the event of a closure
that would help drivers navigate around
an incident the man what a difference
almost 20 years can make tony writes
that because of
apps like waze and the overhead freeway
signs where messages can be changed as
needed
he says they're in the process of
decommissioning what once were seen as
trailblazing signs tony says they cost a
lot to maintain won't be upgraded in
fact he says
they'll all eventually trailblaze into
the sunset
alex thanks for riding buckle up drive
carefully and please put on that phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic eight at eight news now
dot com